alain t'as le bonjour aux le
gouvernement on le disait entendant que
dispenser une formation obligatoire à la
laïcité pour les enseignants d'ici fin
est ce que c'est une bonne chose selon
vous en fait c'est ce que ce qui me
paraît un peu surprenant dans le rapport
dans ce premier point nous explique
effectivement il va une formation qui va
dispenser sa sont obligatoires c'est le
premier point obligatoire si tu nous
entends qu il y aurait des formations
qui ne serait pas obligatoire pour
devenir enseignant on peut en tout cas
pas sur la laïcité c'est premier point
qui paraît ce pour la deuxième fois en
fait normalement ça devrait déjà être
existé je je je considère que ça existe
déjà
après ça pose la question de la
formation initiale des enseignants et de
la formation continue qui n'est pas
satisfaisante selon signal depuis très
longtemps
donc c'est une bonne chose je pense que
sincèrement au risque de vous décevoir
ça ne changera absolument rien à ce qui
se passe actuellement
pourquoi pour revenir vous nous parlez
d'une formation qui n'est pas
satisfaisante à l'heure actuelle
pourquoi
qu'est ce qui ne va pas aujourd'hui pour
vous ça c'est de plus général on
considère que la formation la formation
des enseignants est pas suffisante et
pas satisfaisantes elles correspondent
pas à ce que ce qu'elle tombe les
collègues et les ailes
elle est extrêmement réduite ces
dernières années elle sera encore
réduite
l'année prochaine vous donner une idée
là les futurs enseignants passent un
concours en quatre ans après le bac
après ils ont un an de formation à mi
temps c'est dire qu'ils ont un mois et
la moitié du temps de formation les
résultats en classe à partir de 2022
le concours aura lieu cinq ans après le
bac
les enseignants ou futurs enseignants
seront donc étudiants pendant cinq ans
ils auront un dédommagement d'environ
700 euros là leur dernière année pour
passer une journée en classe et après
ils auront une et à côté de ça ils
auront une formation ça sous-entend en
fait que la formation va être réduite
mais surtout en fait pour devenir
enseignant notamment au premier degré il
faut être titulaire d'un master 2 bac +5
n'importe quel bac + 5 peut faire la
sienne en passant le concours on va être
complètement
il y aura plus besoin du tout formation
les enseignants on se retrouvait ensuite
en classe mis au jour en main donc j'ai
du mal à croire que cette formation
obligatoire qui danse sur glace
d'ailleurs pas seulement aux enseignants
ça s'adresse à l'ensemble de la fonction
publique donc on voit d'ailleurs avoir
un petit peu plus de détails à ce sujet
puisque du coup ça concerne la france on
publique hospitalière ont parlé trois
fonctions publiques
la fonction publique hospitalière donc
les médecins ils vont servir là la
fonction publique territoriale ou dans
les collectivités mais aussi l'ensemble
de la fonction publique d'état donc dans
l'administration dans la police voilà
donc on voudrait avoir un peu plus de
tests sur cette formation obligatoire à
la laïcité
là c'est là c'est un petit peu bague en
tout cas on a tous en tête 1
l'assassinât terrible de votre collègue
samuel pâtit aujourd'hui donc le
gouvernement lui dans ce contexte la
veut renforcer le respect des valeurs de
la république c'est de ça dont il s'agit
une formation pour les enseignants
est-ce que c'est suffisant à ce que
c'est la hauteur des enjeux
moi j'ai surtout l'impression que là ce
que cherche à faire jean michel blanquer
et une vernon c'est celle d'attirer
l'attention sur sur la laïcité sur une
certaine conception de la laïcité
la réalité c'est qu'en fait ce sont des
concepts qui sont qui sont déjà au coeur
de la formation et l'évaluation des
enseignants par exemple l'année dernière
les concours dont peu a pu se passer le
temps que blake de la même façon il n'y
a pas eu de d'épreuves orales pour une
raison sanitaire cette année les
stagiaires enseignants ont passé à 1 une
épreuve à une sorte d' entretien
professionnel
au cours de cet entretien professionnel
ils s'attendaient ils ont été interrogés
sur les valeurs de la république et sur
la laïcité donc c'est quelque chose qui
existe déjà
donc je vois pas ce qui va ce qu'il a
apporté plus ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui à l'école et ça c'est
peut-être sans doute le plus important
c'est c'est le remplacement c'est le
sait les moyens humains au mois de mars
le l'inspecteur d'académie du nord
reconnaissait il y avait 450 classe 450
enseignants qui n'est pas remplacé donc
les enfants pour éviter le brassage ils
sont renvoyés chez eux
le problème c'est pas forcément
l'enseignement de la laïcité le problème
c'est l'enseignement tout court celle ci
d'avoir accès à l'école de façon
continue de avec en envisageant une
continuité pédagogique une véritable
continuité pédagogique et les enfants
qui sont privés d'école
actuellement il n'y a pas de
suffisamment de moyens humains mais
parce que sur ce sujet on entend souvent
des établissements réputés difficiles
dans lequel on pourrait pas parler de
certains sujets d'histoire où certains
sujets 2
de religion c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui est ce qu'une formation
finalement c'est suffisant pour faire
face à ces difficultés notamment de
jeunes enseignants
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre en place
selon vous maintenant effectivement vous
l'avait pointé ce n'est pas suffisant ce
qui compte vraiment c'est un bon voilà
c'est pas de d'ajouter un module de
formation lors de lors de la formation
initiale des enseignants c'est pas ça
qui va changer si si on n'a pas
suffisamment d'enseignants pour
effectivement mettre en avant les
valeurs la république et l'attachement
la laïcité qui est fort d'ailleurs
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait alors
ce n'est peut-être pas suffisant mais
plus de 90% des élèves de 2de 4e et de
3e sont attachés au principe de laïcité
c'est ben ça veut dire qu'il reste huit
ou neuf pour cent c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même de 10% salina qui est quand
même un problème est en fait un problème
c'est une problématique auquel les
enseignants sont attachés et qui est
prise très au sérieux par les
enseignants mais effectivement le
problème c'est pas un juste un module
supplémentaire de formation pendant la
formation initiale des enseignants
le problème c est ce qu on a
suffisamment de moyens humains pour
assurer l'enseignement d'une manière
générale aux maths français ont toutes
les disciplines et y compris sur les
aspects les valeurs républicaines sur
les aspects de la laïcité
mais au delà d'être formés sur les
valeurs de la république est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes enseignants
sont formés à faire face à une classe
plus ou moins difficiles sont formés à
répondre à telle ou telle situation
conflictuelle notamment lors d'un je le
disais lors d'un cours d'histoire géo ou
alors lors d'un cours de révision par
exemple
c'est il ya deux questions dans la
beauce est ce que la formation initiale
est satisfaisante
donc là je leur dis non là c'est la
formation initiale n'est pas
satisfaisante c'est pas suffisant
après comment on fait pour gérer au
quotidien c'est effectivement c'est
coeur du métier on va être mise en
difficulté par certains élèves parfois
sur les valeurs de laïcité barça ce
concerne évidemment plutôt le second
degré mais moi j'ai obligé au téléphone
les collègues qui sont dépassés par part
au quotidien par rapport leur classe par
leurs élèves parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à gérer ses réflexes sont très très
difficile dans le premier degré donc
c'est tout le coeur de du métier c'est
ça va réussir à emmener la classe à
allait les emmener vers la même forme
d'émancipation être capable de
construire un libre arbitre et de se
faire une idée de ce que c'est que
notamment de ce que sont les valeurs de
la république
précisément la laïcité est ce que ça
induit aux usa c'est le coeur du métier
plus donc il faut effectivement une
formation initiale beaucoup plus
complète et puis aussi ça on s'est
précisée évidente le également dans le
dans un rapport une formation continue
qui n'est pas satisfaisante aujourd'hui
dans le premier degré et la formation
continue elle s'est réduite à la portion
congrue
ces 18 heures par an là c'est
actuellement de noël depuis 2 ans et 9
heures français 9 heures match à un
moment où on a dû vivre là pendant un an
et des temps d'enseignement à distance
on aurait espéré que le ministère prenne
pas en compte et propose des temps pour
l'utilisation des outils numériques pour
les présenter aux élèves savoir comment
de faire comment faire classe à distance
la maîtrise des outils techniques
ça n'a pas du tout été abordée alors
qu'on né voilà les les enfants du
premier degré du second degré passe un
certain temps devant des écrans pour
pour apprendre ça a duré toute l'année
à certains moments donc ça n'a pas du
tout été pris en compte on est surpris
que ce soit pas pas pris en compte est
ce qu'il y aura un temps supplémentaire
de formation d'information continue pour
pour enseigner la laïcité
pourquoi pas c'est quelque chose dont
les enseignants se sont déjà emparés au
snuipp fsu on avait organisé en 2016 un
stage syndicales sur la laïcité on avait
invité jean pierre dharréville
on avait eu énormément dans ses mains
qui avaient participé donc c'est quelque
chose auquel les enseignants sont
attachés au cui d'été en formation
supplémentaire alors après est-ce qu'on
doit vraiment faire confiance à jean
pierre robin qui est qui a l'air d'avoir
un point de vue très très très parce que
c'est vrai qu'en personnel sur sur la
question en 2004 il avait déjà publié un
rapport qui avait été controversé
d'ailleurs oui mais qui avait toujours
controversé il a une vision de la
laïcité qui est propre à lui et c'est un
chercheur je vais pas remettre en cause
j'ai pas lu je n'ai pas les compétences
pour le faire mais il a une vision
vision bien à lui de de la laïcité vous
rappelle qu'il était en procès qu'il a
gagné mais ils tiennent dans le procès
est accusé de diffamation vis-à-vis de
la fcpe
voilà une voix s'est il fait partie de
ces gens qui considèrent que l'islamo
gauchisme dans graine l'université est
certaine et certaines associations
certains syndicats et une voix ccifa
voilà c'est tout pour moi c'est un livre
que je vois pas du tout avec disney pour
vous cette question d'islam aux
gauchistes même au sein du des
professeurs des enseignants au collège
absolument pas
le problème de la preuve de la laïcité
géant une égérie j'ai rencontré des
problèmes j'ai été mis en difficulté en
deux le 10 novembre 2014 j'accompagne ma
classe dans le cadre d'une commémoration
de la première guerre mondiale
nous sommes avec une école privée dans
la ville de marrakech travail nous
sommes nés avec des élèves d'une école
privée juste à côté sont présents les
élus et le prêtre de la paroisse locale
qui qui commence un autre père et qui
bénit les élèves moi je suis avec des
enfants d'écoles publiques
il ya rupture de la cité à son nom là il
ya il ya eu un moment pendant pendant le
dix minutes un quart d'heure où les
enfants se sont retrouvés alors on leur
a imposé un temps de 1 temps de
catéchisme chrétiens alors qu'ils sont à
l'école publique
ce qui est sûr un temps l'école publique
là effectivement il ya il ya ce type de
problème je n'ai jamais rencontré
d'autres problèmes vis-à-vis
ça fait 20 ans que j'enseigne et au
quotidien dans mes dans la fonction
syndicale gpad appels de collègues me
disant bon on n'arrive pas à résoudre ce
problème avec des avec des enfants qui
refusent telle ou telle partie du
programme qui accuse de manger avec elle
mais merci pardonnez moi je suis obligé
de vous couper on arrive au terme du
temps qui nous est imparti merci à vous
à l'intérieur il faut merci je rappelle
que vous êtes professeur cosecrétaire
snuipp fsu nord